NEW YORK WE GO, SEAN HANNITY IS
NEXT.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
AS WE HAVE ACCURATELY PREDICTED
RIGHT HERE ON THIS SHOW THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL RELEASED THE
FIRST AND WHAT WILL BE A SERIES
OF REPORTS REGARDING A VARIETY
OF TOPICS.
TODAY’S REPORT AS WE PREVIOUSLY
TOLD YOU, THIS IS THE SMALL ONE,
VERY NARROW IN SCOPE DEALING
SPECIFICALLY WITH ONLY ONE
ISSUE, THAT IS FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JIM COMEY AND HIS
MEMOS.
IN JUST A MOMENT WE WILL BREAK
DOWN ALL THE DETAILS AND WHAT
WAS A DEVASTATING REBUKE OF THE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
TODAY’S NARROW REPORT IS SMALL
IN SCOPE, THE BIG REPORT BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ON FISA ABUSE
IS EXPECTED TO BE DETAILED,
BRUTAL, AND DEVASTATING IN ITS
CONCLUSIONS.
WE CAN TELL YOU, WE EXPECT THAT
REPORT TO DETERMINE THAT THOSE
FISA WARRANTS, THE BACK DOOR
SPYING ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
TRANSITION, THEN PRESIDENCY WERE
IN FACT ILLEGALLY OBTAINED,
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE EXPECTING.
REMEMBER, COMEY SIGNED THREE OF
THE FOUR APPLICATIONS AND THE
ORIGINAL ONE WHICH WAS
OCTOBER 2016 BUT HE TOLD TRUMP
SOMETHING ELSE IN JANUARY.
TODAY THEY RELEASED ONLY A
NARROW SLIVER OF INFORMATION,
IT’S BRUTAL, A SMALL PART OF
WHAT WILL BE COMING IN THE WEEKS
AHEAD.
IT IS A STUNNING AND HARSH
REBUKE TO THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR BUT LET’S BE CLEAR,
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT A FEW WEEKS
AGO WE TOLD YOU EXACTLY WHAT IT
WOULD BE, WE WERE NOT WRONG.
NARROW, LIMITED IN SCOPE WITH
REFERRALS THAT THE AG HAS
DECLINED TO ACT ON.
ALL OF THIS WE REPORTED TO YOU
WEEKS AGO.
TONIGHT, WE DO KNOW JAMES COMEY
IS IN FACT NOT THE SUPER PATRIOT
HE CLAIMS, WE KNOW HIM TO BE A
LEADER AND A BUYER, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOUND THE
DISGRACE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR SET
A DANGEROUS EXAMPLE FOR THE
35,000 CURRENT FBI EMPLOYEES IN
TODAY’S REPORT WAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED REBUKE OF AN FBI
DIRECTOR SURROUNDING HIS
NEFARIOUS PLOT TO SEEK REVENGE
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF IT SHOWS HOW POLITICAL HE WAS
FROM THE GET-GO.
AMERICA’S SELF-PROCLAIMED SUPER
PATRIOT IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
DIRTY, CORRUPT FORMER BUREAUCRAT
THAT WILL BE IN SERIOUS
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL JEOPARDY AS
THIS ALL UNFOLDS.
AFTER HE WAS FIRED, HE LIFTED
SENSITIVE INFORMATION AND SOME
CASES CLASSIFIED GOVERNMENT
MEMOS ABOUT CONVERSATIONS HE HAD
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THEN HE STORED
THESE DOCUMENTS AT HIS HOME AND
LEAKED THESE SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS
AND THE CONTENTS OF THEM I’M A
ONE OF THE MEMOS TO THE PRESS
USING A CLOSE FRIEND AS A
CONDUIT -- THAT WENT TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
HE ALSO USED A PERSONAL EMAIL
ADDRESS TO DISSEMINATE
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL TO HIS OWN
LAWYERS, HE’S SUPPOSED TO GET
THE APPROVAL TO THE FBI, HE
DIDN’T GET THE APPROVAL.
AMONG THE MANY SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS, LET’S GO THROUGH THE
LIST.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND HIS
RETENTION, HANDLING,
DISSEMINATION OF CERTAIN
GOVERNMENT MEMOS VIOLATED THE
DEPARTMENT AND FBI POLICIES AND
HIS EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT.
HE DID NOT SEEK AUTHORIZATION
BEFORE PROVIDING SENSITIVE
GOVERNMENT MEMOS TO HIS
ATTORNEYS, YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO DO
THAT.
ADDITIONALLY HE DIDN’T SEEK FBI
AUTHORIZATION BEFORE PROVIDING
THE CONTENTS TO THE REPORTER.
HE TOLD THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HE DIDN’T
NOTIFY ANYONE AT THE FBI THAT HE
WAS GOING TO SHARE THESE MEMOS
WITH ANYONE.
HE VIOLATED APPLICABLE POLICIES
AND HIS EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT BY
FAILING TO EITHER SURRENDER HIS
COPIES OF THE MEMOS TO THE FBI
OR TO SEEK AUTHORIZATION TO
RETAIN THEM.
ONCE HE KNEW THE FBI HAD
CLASSIFIED PORTIONS OF THE MEMO,
HE HAD PREVIOUSLY GIVEN A MEMO
HE FAILED TO IMMEDIATELY THE FBI
TO HIS ATTORNEYS.
DESPITE KNOWLEDGE THAT MEMOS
CONTAINED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, HE DID NOT
APPROPRIATELY MARK MEMO THREE
WITH BANNERS, OR CLASSIFICATION
AUTHORITY.
HE VIOLATED EXECUTIVE ORDER
13526, AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY APARTMENT AND FBI
POLICIES GOVERNING MARKING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
HE WAS NOT AUTHORIZED TO
DISCLOSE STATEMENTS HE
ATTRIBUTED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHICH WERE RELEVANT TO THE
ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
HE’S ALSO IN CLEAR VIOLATION OF
THE FBI’S THREE PUBLICATION
REVIEW POLICY -- I CAN GO ON AND
ON -- THERE ARE 79 PAGES, 79
ON BECAUSE THIS MEMO WENT ON AND
DEVASTATING PAGES DOCUMENTING
COMEY’S GROSS MISCONDUCT AND
THIS IS JUST AS I SAID -- THIS
IS ONE SMALL SLIVER.
THIS IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
TODAY’S REPORT IS SOLELY AND
VERY NARROWLY FOCUSED ON HIS
ILLICIT LEAKING AT THE
MISHANDLING OF SENSITIVE
GOVERNMENT MEMOS.
THAT IS A SMALL PART OF HIS WEB
OF CORRUPTION.
THIS IS LOW-HANGING FRUIT IF
YOU’RE LOOKING FOR THE BIGGER
PICTURE, WHILE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS DECLINED TO
PROSECUTE WHAT OUR CLEAR
CRIMINAL VIOLATIONS, WE EXPECT
SEVERAL MORE BOMBSHELL REPORTS
IN THE COMING WEEKS INCLUDING
THE BIG REPORT AND AS WE HAVE
MENTIONED THE INVESTIGATION INTO
FISA ABUSE WILL LIKELY DETAIL
HOW CALL ME AND OTHERS COMMITTED
PREMEDITATED FRAUD AGAINST THE
FISA COURT.
IN THAT CASE HE SWORE THE
EVIDENCE WAS VERIFIED, THAT IT
WAS CORROBORATED, THAT IT WAS
TRUE AND MULTIPLE RENEWALS
SIMILARLY WERE VERIFIED,
CORROBORATED, AND TRUE.
HE WANTED TO REQUEST WAS MARKED
"VERIFIED" AT THE TOP OF THE
DOCUMENT.
IT’S RIGHT THERE.
THE EVIDENCE WAS NOT TRUE, IT
WAS NOT ACCURATE AND IT WAS
NEVER VERIFIED, WE HAVE POINTED
OUT ON THIS PROGRAM, WE NOW KNOW
IT WAS UNVERIFIABLE.
IT’S CLAIMS IT DEEMED
UNVERIFIABLE AND WHEN THE FBI
GOT AROUND TO LOOKING INTO THE
VERACITY OF IT, THEY DETERMINED
90 PLUS PERCENT IF NOT ALL OF IT
WAS FALSE.
YET THE WARRANT WAS USED AS THE
BULK OF INFORMATION TO GET THE
WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE BUT
ALSO A BACKDOOR TO SPY ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, THE TRUMP TRANSITION
TEAM, AND THE PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT, "IT CAN BE A
FELONY TO CONCEAL RELEVANT
INFORMATION AND DECEIVE THE FISA
COURT, I HAVE A DOZEN STATUTES
MAKE IT A CRIME TO PERPETUATE
FRAUD INCLUDING DEPRIVATION OF
RIGHTS, PERJURY AND FALSE
STATEMENTS, YOU CAN ADD TO THAT
SEVERAL OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
AND FRAUD STATUTES THAT ALL
WOULD BE APPLICABLE."
THOSE ARE DEVASTATING CHARGES
CALL ME AND OTHERS COULD BE
FACING IN THE COMING WEEKS BUT
THAT’S NOT ALL.
ANOTHER MASSIVE INVESTIGATION
WHICH I BELIEVE WILL BECOME THE
BIGGEST PART OF ALL OF THIS
ABUSE OF POWER, THAT SURROUNDS
THE ORIGINS OF THE WITCH HUNT.
THAT PROBE NOW BEING CONDUCTED
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND BY
JOHN DURHAM IS FOCUSED ON HOW
JAMES COMEY, HOW JOHN BRENNAN,
JAMES CLAPPER, WEAPONIZE THE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE
THAT WE CAN TRUST TO THESE BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN IN OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND THEY
WEAPONIZE THEM AGAINST ALL
THINGS DONALD TRUMP.
WHETHER OR NOT THE OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THIS IS GOING TO
BE THE BIG QUESTION IN ALL OF
THIS SOLICITED INTEL AGENCIES TO
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAW TO DO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR OTHER
THE SPYING THAT THEY CAN’T DO ON
AMERICANS.
THAT WOULD BE A SERIOUS CRIME.
THE BIGGER ISSUE BECOMES WHY DID
PRESIDENT OBAMA BEGIN A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST AN
INCOMING PRESIDENT?
HE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THERE IS NO COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
CAMPAIGN, IT IS NEVER CONDUCTED
ON
UNLESS IT IS A PRESIDENT’S, THAT
MEANS THE PRESIDENT HAD TO HAVE
KNOWLEDGE AND WE KNOW FROM THE
PETER STRZOK-LISA PAGE TEXTING,
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTED TO BE
INFORMED EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THE EMAIL
FROM SUSAN RICE TO HERSELF ON
THE VERY DAY OF TRUMP’S
INAUGURATION.
SHE RANDOMLY DOCUMENTED A
CONVERSATION WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA ABOUT THE RUSSIA
WITCH HUNT WRITING
"PRESIDENT OBAMA BEGAN THE
CONVERSATION BY STRESSING HIS
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS ISSUE IS
HANDLED BY THE INTELLIGENCE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES BY
THE BOOK."
WOW.
THE DONALD TRUMP IS BEING
INAUGURATED AS PRESIDENT, THAT
HAPPENED WEEKS AGO, WHY DOES SHE
FEEL THE NEED TO WRITE THAT NOTE
TO SELF?
WHY DID SHE SENT HERSELF A MEMO
ON OBAMA’S LAST DAY AND TRUMP’S
FIRST DAY?
MORE IMPORTANTLY, OBAMA, BIDEN,
RICE, LYNCH, KLAPPER, COMEY,
WANTED ALL OF THESE PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND WHEN DID THEY
KNOW WHAT?
WHAT WAS THE JUSTIFICATION?
AS FOR SUPER PATRIOT OF
JIM COMEY, HE’S STILL LIVING IN
THAT ALTERNATIVE REALITY OF HIS,